mein thema was ich mitgemacht habe ist
das thema kinderarmut die jetzige
regierungskoalition die sich aufmachen
in deutschland zurückkehren aus linken
also aus grünen spd und deren und der
fdp hat gesagt sie will die kinderarmut
bekämpft das finde ich richtig wir haben
2,8 millionen kinder die die kinderarmut
leben jedes fünfte kind bei mir im
wahlkreis ist es teilweise jedes zweite
nun sagt man mal will dass für bestimmte
gruppen tun und alle grundleistungen
zusammentun das alleine reicht nach
meinem dafürhalten nicht aus weil es
gibt viele pakete zur teilhabe von
bildung am sportunterricht zeit zu haben
einen unterschiedlichen klassenfahrten
am nachhilfeunterricht und die kommen
einfach nicht an bei einzelnen sachen
sind das bis zu fünf prozent die
ankommen 95 prozent der mittel gegen die
familien gar nicht extrem bürokratisch
unregelmäßig im jahr zu beantragen und
anstatt einen digitalen kinder atlas
oder eine digitale kinder app zu haben
bei der diese leistung eben auch ankommt
macht man an der stelle gar nichts man
hat nur einer ganz billigen gruppe jetzt
zugesagt das thema kindergrundsicherung
zu lösen ich finde das ist nicht
ausreichend und ich finde das muss man
in dieser zeit auch diskutiert aber sie
wollen ja künftig generalsekretär werden
der cdu und ihr plädoyer nein er aber
mich wundert ein kleines bisschen wenn
wir uns auf die letzten 16 jahre mal
kaprizieren da müssen wir schon gut sie
haben dem argument wahrscheinlich
gerechnet es ist die cdu mit einer
kanzlerin angela merkel die dieses land
regiert hat die auch ganz ganz viele
bundesländer regiert hat und ich hab mir
die zahl noch einmal angeschaut haben
den fettesten sozialstaat aller zeiten
1,2 millionen euro fließen pro jahr oder
werden umverteilt ein drittel dessen was
in deutschland überhaupt erwirtschaftet
wird fließt also in sozialer so viel wie
nie zuvor in der amtszeit von angela
merkel hat sich dieser betrag um mehr
als 50 prozent erhöht also die cdu hat
in ihrer regierungszeit den sozialstaat
ganz ganz fett gemacht und jetzt klagen
sie in allen ehren aber darüber dass ist
offenbar zuviel kinderarmut geht das
lässt mich zumindest ratlos zurück weil
ich den eindruck gewinnen können doch
viele in der runde viele zuschauer hat
auch die cdu ist die partei die dieses
problem lösen kann warum wollen sie es
ausgerechnet jetzt lösen wenn sie
opposition sind also erstens nicht alles
in der zeit ist ausreichend erledigt
worden sonst bräuchten wir jetzt keine
politik mehr und auch keine neue
regierung das zweite der anstieg der war
so gut dass die innere oder hauptstadt
anstieg der sozialausgaben hat viel mit
dem zuschuss in die rentenversicherung
zu tun das ist der größte und der
wesentliche anstieg gut ein drittel des
bundeshaushaltes sind es staatlicher
zuschuss in die rentenversicherung aber
der anstieg ist keine 500 milliarden
also wenn wir von rund 700 auf 1,2
billionen kommen ja dann ist der
zuschuss in die rentenkasse liegt bei
etwas über 100 milliarden das macht den
kohl nicht fett dass das wesentliche ist
aus meiner sicht beim thema
kindergrundsicherung auch gar nicht die
frage dass ich neue zusätzliche mittel
zusammen packe um die
kindergrundsicherung zu geben da ist für
mich eher das wesentliche das
beispielsweise die kindergrundsicherung
nicht angerechnet wird und auf hartz iv
angerechnet wird wenn das kind die zeit
und noch eine zeitung aus trägt oder
nebenher jemand arbeitet dass das dann
auf das gesamtvermögen an gerät also auf
die gesamteinnahme angerichtet wird
halte ich nicht für gerecht sondern wir
will jeder immer dieses thema kommt ganz
auf von politikern weiß auch so wichtig
ist warum hat noch niemand geändert mit
jedem politiker fassen dem ich spreche
der sagt wie kann es sein dass bei hartz
4 empfängern die kinder das ist
angerechnet wird ich verstehe es auch
nicht wie kann das sein dem eh schon
weniger und dann sollen sie noch was von
ihrem nebenjob abgeben und anstatt zu
lernen leistung lohnt sich von klein auf
lernen sie nur einmal muss schauen wie
viel der staat der familie gefahr sich
noch dazu verdienen kann und den
schwarzen schwan sie hat das haus
schwarz machen haben wir das nie
abgeschafft da das ist eine sehr gute
frage ich bin seit ungefähr vier wochen
im deutschen bundestag und unfähigkeit
dazu beitragen die der wesentliche punkt
der mich ärgert ist die jetzigen
parteien die sich aufgemacht haben zu
regieren das linksliberale bündnis das
da zusammen getreten ist hat in den
programmen geregelt wir wollen das
angehen und wenn man da in
sondierungsgruppe zu nichts mehr drin
soll man sagt will sich die besonders
bedürftige gruppe anschauen und für die
die bestehenden leistungen besser
bündeln aber wir haben so viele angebote
an bildung und teilhabe die den kindern
eben nicht zuteil wird weil sie extrem
bürokratisch ist all das was wir über
die schulleitung an die kinder geben für
die klassenfahrt für die klamotten für
den sportunterricht das funktioniert
alles was die eltern beim amt beantragen
müssen ist extrem kompliziert wenn wir
eine kindergrundsicherung sap haben wenn
wir eine reine dinge ansprechen rät
jetzt also wir sind noch nicht einmal
die neue regierung ist noch nicht einmal
im amt ist noch geschäftsführend im amt
und der künftige generalsekretär der cdu
ich sage es jetzt einfach mal so wer
sagt schon was die noch nicht im amt
befindliche regierung falsch gemacht hat
obwohl ihre partei 16 jahre regiert hat
der schweizer auch möglich germany
in der schweiz aus der schweizer blick
ist gefragt
diese diskussionen über den deutschen
sozialstaat die vielen bei mir immer
gleich zu seiner zweckbestimmung
die komplexe weiter senken eigentlich
der deutsche sozialstaat ist ein
deprimierendes thema ich muss dann immer
schauen dass ich eh nicht unter den
tisch die komplexität dieses
sozialstaats ist so groß und das ich je
gearbeitet habe haben schon führende
sozialdemokraten geklagt darunter herr
steinmeier das ist glaube ich heute
bundespräsident gesagt ja wissen sie
herr körper im deutschen sozialstaat da
wird das geld mit beiden händen zum
fenster rausgeworfen und wir wissen gar
nicht wie wieder stoppen können wie sie
wenn der staat aber wir müssen jetzt die
kinder da die kinder hochbau und da
können sie davon ausgehen dass diese
kinder die beide nicht profitieren ich
meine was ist die aufgabe des staates
bei der kinderarmut du musst die kinder
und die kletterstange heranführen du
musst schauen dass jeder an die
kletterstange kommt aber klettern müssen
sie dann selber aber in deutschland also
mit allem respekt das gilt bei uns auch
wir haben einen aus holz staat einen
universellen bemusterung start der
möchte uns jetzt ja auch schon in die
körpersäfte hinein regieren möchte uns
das impfen befehlen er will die
kindererziehung übernehmen wird die
kinder an sich nehmen der staat
übernimmt sich und der staat wird die
resultate nicht produziert ein zweiter
punkt den ich beobachte da weiß ich
nicht wie es in deutschland ist in der
schweiz beobachten wir auch dass diese
willkommenskultur nicht wahr diese etwas
united colors of benetton kultur dass
man auf viele unterschiedlichen kulturen
da hat wo es dann halt schwierig ist und
wo tatsächlich dann tatsächlich
nachteile draußen sondern auch die
lehrer überfordert sind sehr
anspruchsvoll wie man das machen kann
ich glaube das kind egal woher sie
kommen wenn der staat es nicht vertuscht
dann hast du keinen ehrgeiz und die
kinder wollen ja lernen sie wollen
sicher durchsetzen und irgendwie ist das
für mich jetzt einmal zeigen was sie
gesagt haben deutschland ist für mich
immer das land ist der soziale mobilität
gewesen des sozialen aufstiegs und wenn
es sogar ein cdu politiker sagt dass
sich die kritik gegen das sitzenbleiben
da muss ich mir also ernsthaft die frage
stellen was ist dir eigentlich in
deutschland los mit problem in
deutschland ist einfach dass die politik
jedoch ebenfalls überdenken möchte und
lösen möchte hat aber noch nie
funktioniert wir sehen doch seit 20
jahren auch mit der spd oder mit der cdu
komplettes versagen diesbezüglich egal
ob es bei infrastruktur ist
internetausbau oder bei bildung also das
2,8 millionen kinder in deutschland in
der armut leben ist es ist ein
armutszeugnis bei einem der reichsten
länder der welt dann müssen wir doch das
grundübel mal anpacken wie so können
diese menschen nicht genug geld
verdienen wir haben noch gute jobs
überall warum kriegen das nicht hin dass
die kinder oder die eltern dieser kinder
gutes geld verdienen warum sehen wir
nicht die möglichkeit geben in zukunft
eine perspektive zu geben und da möchte
ich die politik auch an klagen weil sie
mitnehmen immer noch mehr geld in die
hand und keine einzige partei hat in
ihrem programm über die demographie
gesprochen zum beispiel also die
tickende zeitbomben dass die blumen in
rente gehen es kommen immer weniger
kinder nach diesen teilweise in prekären
arbeitssituationen hat ich muss mich
erst auf ihren displays möglich weil ich
sehe einfach sie haben zwar hehre ziele
aber sie werden auch das imponiert
werden glaube ich beim nächsten mal
klappt es mir das klar war so
sozialsenator ich weiß es ist glaube ich
sogar sehr sympathisch das ist glaube
ich das glaube ich übrigens nicht weil
wir haben auch in meiner amtszeit als
sozialsenator versucht viele dieser
programme den schulsekretärin an die
hand zu geben die zu befähigen an den
schulen dass sie den kindern die
programme zum beispiel für die klamotten
für den sportunterricht darüber
finanzieren über die budgets die an den
schulen sind was zum vorteil dass die
kinder dann eben auch mut hatten in den
sportunterricht zu gehen weil sonst
gesagt haben da gehe ich nicht hin weil
ich habe gar nicht die klamotten und der
papa kann das gar nicht bezahlen das
zweite ist
jedenfalls das was sie aus meinem
wahlkreis kenne das sind nicht die
kinder von eltern die nicht arbeiten
sondern das sind kinder von eltern die
aber angehende freien aufstocken müssen
ja nicht bei denen bei denen dann der
bürokratische aufwand das nicht in dem
schuljahres rhythmus sondern im
halbjahresrhythmus beim amt beantragen
zu müssen die zusätzlichen mittel das
sie laufend in diese bürokratie falle
kommen sie schon grundeinkommen wird
kommen von einer kindergrundsicherung
ist das was diskutiert wird mein
eindruck ist aber dass die der
leistungen für bildung und teilhabe die
die kinder haben könnten um
gleichberechtigt mit den anderen kindern
diese chancen wahrzunehmen und an die
kletterstange zu kommen einmal im bild
zu bleiben